you did a was it you did a stand-up a
special called big underwear and we
talked primarily about your underwear
Wow why are you so fascinated with your
underwear not I'm not fast but when I
was a kid that was we were very poor so
I had very few underwear and so I must
have bought them all the time I empty I
found out I was on underwear hoarder you
know but the thing that made me realize
I had big underwear was I was fooling I
got him out of the dryer and I lift them
up I go are these mine when you block
out the Sun with your underwear
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and no one wants them I gave six boxes a
big in underwear from the storage and I
brought it with goodwill and they go we
can't take out it's not sanitary they're
not dirty yeah and I thought I'll leave
them there and then I thought oh what a
story that would be Louie Anderson
leaves his underwear at the goodwill
yeah but here's the worst thing I'm
driving home there's a homeless guy you
know and I really do care a lot about
the homeless and I say he obviously
needs some underwear he's a big guy and
I thought I'm gonna pull over and then I
played it in my head my way you know hey
hey I got some underwear in the bag it's
not good can't ask you about baskets
baskets has been this has been such a
great role for you you play Zach
Galifianakis is mom you play as mom
Christina what I love is that you really
don't behave very differently it's just
it's so great it's such a perfect role
for you I'm so blessed and grateful and
just I get to play my mom who was a
wonderful person raised eleven kids and
I get to celebrate her no and the best
part
[Applause]
you